well today's news conference the
president suggested he might be willing
to believe Putin's denials that Russia
meddled in our last presidential
election watch so I have great
confidence in my intelligence people but
I will tell you that President Putin was
extremely strong and powerful in his
denial today
well that set off a tidal wave of
criticism former CIA director John
Brennan tweeted and we're quoting Donald
Trump's press conference performance in
Helsinki rises to and exceeds the
threshold of high crimes and
misdemeanors in other words grounds for
impeachment and we're quoting now it was
nothing short of treasonous not only
were Trump's comments imbecilic he is
wholly in the pocket of Putin Republican
patriots : where are you what to make of
all this joining us now is a man who has
covered several Russia US summits around
the world and why you professor emeritus
and nation contributing editor Stephen
Cohen one of the country's preeminent
Russia scholars professor Cohen thanks a
lot for joining us assess if you would
the reaction today to this press
conference into the summit between Putin
and Trump the reaction by the most of
the media by the Democrats by the
anti-trump people is like mob violence
I've never seen anything like it in my
life this is the President of the United
States doing what every president Tocker
since Franklin Delano Roosevelt did in
1943 was Stalin meeting with the head of
the Kremlin and every president since
Eisenhower a Republican by the way has
met with the leader of the Kremlin but
one existential purpose to avoid war
between the two nuclear superpowers
today in my considered scholarly long
time judgment relations between the
United States and Russia are more
dangerous than they have ever let me
repeat ever been including the Cuban
Missile Crisis
I want my president to do I didn't vote
for this president but I want my
president to do
what every other president has done sit
with the head of the other nuclear
superpower and walk back the conflicts
that could lead the war whether they be
in Syria Ukraine in the Baltic nations
in these accusations of cyberattacks
every president has been encouraged to
do that and applauded by both parties
not Trump look what they did to them to
him today they held a kangaroo court
they found him guilty and then you have
a former head of the United States CIA
who himself ought to be put under oath
and asked about his role in inventing
Russia gate calling the president the
United States treasonous what have we
come to in this country and what's gonna
happen in seizure well that those are
questions that adults ought to be
discussing I think but let's tell me if
my assessment is wrong it seems almost
as if some on our leadership class on
both sides Republicans and Democrats
seek increased conflict with Russia do
you think that's right and if it is why
all right you've asked a fundamental
question do they know what they're doing
I don't know they seem to hate or resent
the idea of Trump as president that
they've all lost all sense of American
national security I would ask them a
question if you ever get these people on
asking this question for yourself for me
for the nation do you these people who
are hunting Trump do you prefer trying
to impeach Trump to trying to avert war
with nuclear Russia that's the bottom
line and that's where we're at today
because when I listen what is the summit
that's what they're doing and I'm in no
way defending Russia about you know with
which I have no connection whatsoever
and I'm basically agnostic and I take it
as a matter of faith that they seek to
influence US government undermine our
elections none of that surprises me at
all I just don't understand why Russia
uniquely is considered an unacceptable
partner for conversation while at the
same time we are happy to have close
intimate relations with Saudi Arabia for
example the government of China for
example both more repressive
than the government of Russia
I'm missing this why the emphasis on
Russia people have written books about
this historians why is it that Russia
seems to be our Wicked Witch of the East
when Russia has more in common with the
United States it's Christian country
it's a big country it was a frontier
country we were war allies during World
War two I mean Russia this will upset
people but historically Russia defeated
Nazi Germany in Europe we defeated the
Japanese in the Pacific we were great
allies after that things went bad who's
to blame historians have written lots of
books but why since the end of the
Soviet Union
there's no communism let me ask you a
question you know DC why do these people
dislike Putin the president of post
communist Russia more than they ever
seemed to have disliked the communist
leaders it's more about us Tucker
than it's about them and this is really
dangerous not permitting the President
of the United States to keep us safe and
I think it is no defensive Putin to ask
that exact question I'm just going to
repeat it for our viewers in case they
missed it why do so many people in
charge now dislike the current leader of
Russia more than they dislike the
Communists who killed 10 civilians I
don't know I can't answer it but thank
you there is an answer but we need a lot
of time and a second will happen I hope
you'll come down a sec hi thank you
great to see you professor Stephen Cohen